[Music]
in don't wanna plug news oh please don't
pull that sing compliant on when is it
okay to play me off or not which I never
do it my bootys being spilt Oh fresh
laundry you gotta pull that out today
fresh laundry copay shion's written off
by doctors were really aided by an AI
system that correctly predicted they
would awaken they get them alive that's
[ __ ] crazy
hey I kept humans alive well if I said
they're not gonna die yes that's exactly
what Jane but the doctor said they're
done for and in the AI is like I don't
think so my calculations is saying that
they will [ __ ] calculations I said
when they woke up the AI was like yeah
how does the AI do this okay so I'll do
some example collagen there are 23
points on a coma recovery scale mm-hmm
there was this 19 year old patient who
spent six months with unresponsive
wakefulness syndrome formerly known as
being an event in a vegetative state but
now they call it unresponsive
wakefulness syndrome because the
vegetable got pissed broccoli and I
don't want you using my term on these
people are inferior now you know what
they said they're concerned ability I
just pictured vegetables talking tomato
came at my sausage party yeah like a
[ __ ] cauliflowers like man what the
[ __ ] serious yeah yeah it's like the V
word is only for us you guys didn't earn
the B word yep that's how they
communicate it's 23 points right on this
scale so this 19 year old the doctors
gave him a seven out of 23 after the AI
whoa
through went through his brain scans
because they're saying that this
algorithm can detect certain things at
human eyes can't mmm and so this
algorithm gave him more than 20 points
close to a bowl scores so then later on
the he ended up waking up this oh the
scale is torn up to 23 okay thought it
was there's like a twenty four point
checklist let's go I'll just kill ya
so then this other case there was this
41 year old female stroke victim who was
in that vegetative state for three
months and the doctors gave her a score
of six so the computer gave her a
20-point 23 she woke up oh this other
one yeah I want to see the doctor to go
it I get the Olympic in the coalmine 23
yeah they don't take it all so [ __ ]
seriously yeah they're unbiased these
three patients the doctors said they
will never wake up like was telling the
patient's families you know you should
consider your options here because it
cost a lot of money to keep these people
in the medical facility and keep them
alive and so the computer after giving
them these scores appeasing the computer
predicted that they will wake up within
12 months and that's exactly what
happened within a year they woke up
saying singularity is gonna happen bro
like so soon died is gonna take doctor's
jobs no they're saying that they will
never replace doctors jobs because
they're just trying to see you have you
seen what a [ __ ] robot can do i I
think it had a grape and it performs
surgery and other da Vinci yeah yes what
makes you think that they're not gonna
replace talk doctors are you the one
using it though well way to shut me up -
wait so you saying it's like gloves it's
like for now for now - well sure for now
I mean that's how they do like LASIK and
like ICL and stuff yeah like this like
super precise machine like a bomb squad
machine kinda there's like a little joy
but the it has AI has its own algorithm
the trace like your eyeball but then you
still need that doctor's guidance and to
deal with that's scary yeah so they and
they are saying that the machines not
obviously not perfect it has a 90%
accuracy assessment ratio
like they're better doctors they're
failing how many percent i gamble with
way less you mean I take 90% hey I am
the grabber claw machines cuz those
things like oh yeah 1% success [ __ ]
with you - they do it enough to where it
picks it up and it goes nah [ __ ]
no they don't even drop it there here's
the [ __ ] hold it's like this we need
that [ __ ] dude there's a compilation of
people that know how to gain that [ __ ]
don't like bang it on the side they do
this stuff and then don't [ __ ] get
all the prizes one where it was a whole
bunch of cellphones on a shelf and then
they put the claw weight to the corner
and then just lifted the shelf and all
the phones came out oh that's the best
day that kid's life yeah oh they're
grown adults it's sad it's always sad my
favorite one is when I see this grown
man standing at the machine that slowly
builds the blocks and you're trying to
time it and it always [ __ ] up at the
top and they keep putting money in it's
just like an idiot test I love that I
did that as a kid with the vending
machine where it's like you know the one
that's like a swirly light that's like a
spring and then you have like a Twix bar
when you buy it just spins forward and
drops it what's the--and I would see it
I'm like oh so that's how it works and
you kind of just tilt the vending
machine and all the first ones kind of
just all fall down no [ __ ] ten people
died there trying it's like huge like
people try to drag it down but kind of
people that died gonna get [ __ ]
smashed by the vending machine stand in
front of it I go to the side off the
wall but I already thought this through
the walls yeah yeah good that's the way
to do it now all these things are gonna
try it don't cuz my mommy didn't buy me
snacks now it's kind of a surprise you
know it doesn't always work
so that one's kind of a game - yeah yeah
we're that little black thing like kind
of and then the Twix Market stopping me
like yeah I lost the goddamn game I want
to know the 10% that times that it
hasn't worked though I'll tell you there
was this one where there's 36 year-old
man who suffered a bilateral brain stem
damage after a stroke he was given low
scores by both the doctors and AI but he
was still able to fully recover in less
than a year because family did not give
up on it
Oh obviously so up to the family to take
what they're hearing and give it a shot
exactly I were the be in a coma or be
dead than to be awake in a vegetative
state yeah they're saying that that's
[ __ ] scary five coffins where people
come out of it not all the time we're
living cool when people come out of it
right like what have you heard any
stories of like what they go through and
all that stuff cuz I'm just curious like
where's your memory like you know when
something really flicked tragic happens
near life you tend to block it out I
wonder if how much of that would even
stay selective memory he feels like a
dream I just know the all the
information I know from comas are for
movies great how reliable is they always
come out like this it's never calm it's
never like and they think look at their
hand they're like oh yeah and then they
like oh my god Bart's right dude didn't
she do that in Kill Bill
she is like she was like she's coming
out of water oh yeah every single time
it's always like you think that's a coma
imagine awake vegetative state your
brain is working your eyes are working
you can't say [ __ ] you're just like this
you can't same human family talking [ __ ]
well that's fine they always talk and
then you wake up and you're just like
and I've seen people like find ways to
communicate like even if they can at
least move their eyes they'll like move
and hold a sign that says yes or no and
then community that's fine but still
sucks
but there's this where you just can't do
anything yeah make your eye go right if
it's me if it means yes and it doesn't
even move I know Stephen Hawkins man he
has well he had eventually he had the
things where he was
looking at the words and then they would
say that see really yeah because he
couldn't move anything so what if he
never had that computer we were all
would have missed up on some pretty
pretty cool stuff yeah yeah he's there
to remind us how stupid we all are mhm
mhm every day is this AI thing attached
to the person like is that like
electrodes or some [ __ ] or how does AI
work I'm not sure exactly if just as its
analyzes the brain analyze the brain the
brain can oh and deliberate how active
the brain is in a task and like how are
the neurons firing or whatever the way I
have a picture cuz I'm not exactly sure
how it is it's kind of like you know you
see the doctors are looking at charge
moves out and picturing it not picture
something else hot doctors on a TV show
or looking you charts right - yeah yeah
super hot and then they're just looking
at the the little what is it squiggle
yeah the squiggly line and they're like
nah this fool is never gonna wake up and
then the computer scans it and they're
like no yeah there's like a lot of lines
in there you can't see with your human
eye that's how I think if I was a dog
operating this machine I would scan my
balls for sure I would get my balls I
would see like what does this AI give
the score of my balls this is why we
would not be doctors brain and brain
wrinkles yeah are they well I'll put my
ball wrinkles on there I'd be like damn
my balls are kind of in a vegetative
state let's check them out
you know what kind of looks like brains
- the guts oh yeah wrinkly we could
trick it into checking out our guts -
yeah yeah all this balls is good - I'll
have to get bored of the ball you need
somethin else you go to the cadaver room
when you plug a cadaver and you get the
intestines out what again guys your
balls in it comes out your [ __ ] number
system is not school she was defying
like anything see I've got you that's
funny
[Music]